welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Dr Frank SAU Frank is head of
research at The medis Institute for
strategy and foresight Frank welcome to
the podcast hi Hi Gus thanks for having
me great we're going to talk about
autonomous Weapons Systems so what are
these systems and what would be some
examples I I guess I should start by
saying I usually don't use the term
autonomous weapons systems instead I
talk about autonomy in weapon systems
now that might sound like super nitpicky
what is the difference it is actually a
huge difference because the way I think
about these things and the way I think
we should all be thinking about these
things is in a functional manner rather
than a categorical manner now what does
it mean let's start at the beginning I
think the the the cleanest and um
shortest way to define what the whole
discussion about is when we talk about
autonomy weapons systems is that there's
something happening that we also see in
you know a whole range of other aspects
or fields in life because technolog is
advancing and what happens is that
specific functions are being delegated
from humans to
machines and with regard to weapon
systems the discussion is around the
so-called critical functions in the
targeting cycle of the weapon system and
that is the selection engagement of
targets and so when we're talking about
autonomic weapon systems we're talking
about the selection and engagement of
targets without human intervention the
machine is selecting and engaging uh the
machine is selecting where military
force is to be applied that's not
necessarily a new thing it's not
necessarily an AI thing and it's not
necessarily a problematic thing but
there is a whole range of issues you
know that's crowded around this that we
can talk about just to to make sure I I
get you correct corly here what is
important is the autonomy the the
software so to speak and and that could
be implemented in in ground robots or
drones or perhaps um vessels that that
function at Sea and so what what's
what's the core here is is the
autonomous decision making about who to
Target and and whether to to Target them
that's correct it is super important to
um separate the whole discussion from
that concerned us you know some 15 20
years ago surrounding drones this is not
about drones this is about any
perceivable weapon system floating in
space flying through the air being
submerged Under the Sea traveling the
surface of the sea traveling at land or
you know whatever maybe even in cyers
space you know it is it is purely a
thing of functionality and the question
who or what human or machine is deciding
what when and where why are militaries
interested in autonomy in Weapons
Systems I got into the whole um field in
2007 um I remember this quite well
because I read a paper by Ron Arin uh
from George Tech and this paper was
about I think the title read something
like an ethical Governor uh for
Battlefield robots and I read this and I
was like this got to be joke you know
that was back in the day when we were
talking about remotely piloted drones
and what they mean from a legal
perspective from a politic perspective
from an ethical perspective and you know
here Arin is says hey we we will do all
of this via software we will take the
human out of the equation and his one of
his key arguments really was that that
would make war much more Humane and uh
you know would reduce dramatically the
amount of atrocities and war crimes
being committed so that that was at the
very beginning that was a an important
argument in the whole debate like take
humans out of the equation because you
humans do terrible things to each other
in war which is true and so we will end
up with a much more u Way of War
fighting additional arguments were put
forward over time you know you could say
that it's much more um coste effective
to have one human pilot a whole range of
system systems for instance um and and
you know I could go into more you know
tangential I think arguments that have
been you know put forward the main
reason in my mind is speed it's all
about military military Effectiveness
and Military Effectiveness in terms of
speed and speed meaning um the
completion of the kill chain or the
targeting cycle before your adversary
has done that that will win you
technically speaking every single
engagement when you done with finding
fixing tracking selecting and engaging
the Target and applying Force to it
while your you know adversary is still
remotely piloting this thing and data is
being bounced back back and forth
between the machine and the human while
your machine is doing all of this
internally you're winning that's that's
it you you're
faster and that is I think the main
reason and the main driver behind all of
it what about the trouble that
militaries have that attracting and
training humans to to become soldiers
because this is my impression is that
this might be getting harder perhaps
people have more options than in the
past and in the and the the human cost
to to a a turning dead soldier is is
enormous um and so is that also
something that that militaries are are
thinking about yes I mean if you look at
a country like Japan for instance
they're quite reluctant to be doing
anything about this at the international
stage at this point because they're
looking at at their at their country and
they're saying we got a you know a
problem in terms of demography you need
fairly young fairly fit people to build
an army and that is definitely in all
the C countries that is an issue and so
I would say that is definitely factoring
in uh this notion of having to have a
certain
mass in your armed forces that if you
can't fill it with actual people in
Boots you have to generate some other
way and that would be machines so that's
the perceived value for militaries of
autonomy in Weapons Systems how do you
think that perceived value holds up to
to the actual value so this is where we
need to start differentiating let's
start with you know this point Mass the
importance of mass can be seen in
Ukraine every day like it's not like
they go through hundreds and thousands
of artillery shells every day they are
losing about 10,000 of those quadcopter
drones per month 10,000 per month and so
you can see that even a comparably
smaller fighting force like Ukraine can
leverage technology can Leverage in this
case mass or what we would call trable
systems systems that that are throw away
basically that you can afford to be
losing in great numbers to fight a
successful fight against a an adversary
that has more people more tanks more
artillery more everything and so purely
from a point of military Effectiveness I
think there is something to that also
there's something to that in terms of
this speeding up the targeting cycle I
mean that is also something that Ukraine
has demonstrated you know superbly like
all of NATO is looking at this and
thinking oh we got to be doing this you
know they use these drones they do uh
surveillance and reconnaissance they
find a target the target is immediately
um the target CET are immediately going
to the artillery artillery starting
firing and they're directing the the
fire of the artillery and they're they
have within minutes they can destroy it
a Target Dynamic Target so that is also
something that is that is that has to do
with autonomy that has to do with
automating specific instances in in the
targeting cycle and that that is
definitely you know increasing military
Effectiveness and another thing that
they will put
forward is if I may um this whole notion
of maybe being more precise and thus
more compliant with International
humanitarian law it's extremely um
important to be very careful at this
point and to not conflate any of these
things like Precision guided Munitions
are not necessarily making you more
compliant with International
humanitarian law I can very precisely
kill all the wrong people as we've seen
I would say for instance with drone
stries if
autonomy gives you let's say
hypothetically speaking and there are
ways that you could be you
know constructing a scenario where that
actually works this way if autonomy
gives you more Precision then precision
gives you the opportunity to fight in a
more legally compliant manner that is
also an argument that I think you can't
just wipe away and say no no that's
nonsense if we were to say like in a pro
and con kind of way those are the the
pros then there's a whole bunch of cons
obviously that go against this that are
ethical in nature that have something to
do with you with uh humanitarian law and
that also um you know touch on the
military reality on the ground in terms
of controlling what your weapon systems
are doing Blue on Blue engagements or
you know um escalations that are
unintended and all these kinds of that's
why we're having a debate you know we've
had this debate for for in the UN at
least for nine almost 10 years now uh if
all these things were just you know
squeaky clean and easy and would you
know be better for everybody across the
board we wouldn't be debating yeah so
there are costs and and benefits uh on
balance do you think militaries should
want autonomy in Weapons Systems
it depends on what they use it for I
mean as I said in the beginning it's not
new the way I've been laying it out
dysfunctional way of thinking about it
we've had had autonomy for decades okay
for instance in specific terminal
defense systems like the Fine's fast
firing gun on Navy vessels for instance
you know Patriot missile defense which
this just the times we live in I have to
be pointing to Ukraine again um where
patri is on a daily basis you know
almost on a daily basis defending
against incoming Russian missiles and
you know saving lives
effective and all these system Patriots
for instance or fallons they can be you
know switched to an automatic mode where
the weapon system is looking for targets
selecting those targets engaging the
targets which can go terribly wrong as
we've seen with Patriot and blue onblue
engagements for instance 2003 in Iraq
what is Blue on Blue engagement fr side
of friendly fire when you fire at your
own forces yeah and so as I said we've
had these things we've had them for many
years I think they are um valuable in
terms of Defending against
material missiles mortar shells
artillery shells coming in the question
really is now the time that we live in
now with the technology advancing and
with uh specifically object recognition
being built into weapon systems what
what happens if this Niche capability of
Defending against something that is
flying towards you is now moving out
into every conceivable weapon system
that is you know buzzing you know some
place and looking for targets and this
is obviously where the problems begin so
as I said it is not new and it is not
necessarily problematic but it can get
very problematic if you start using it
in an irresponsible manner I'd say so
yes to answer your question military
should want autonom in weapon Sy systems
but they should be quite careful uh in
the way they deploy them and the way
they use them and they we should be you
know having lots and lots of debates
more debates and good rules and
regulations and specific prohibitions
too um with regard to how we use it in a
responsible manner there's a continuous
development of autonomy it's not like
there's a there's a discreet event in
which we can call this system autonomous
and also what what I what I heard you
say was that I heard you mention as
positive examples of autonomy more
defensive weapons and as as negative
examples more offensive weapons would
would that be a fair dichotomy to to be
more worried about the offensive side
unfortunately no if you you know dig
deeper and you if you start to think
about it a bit more then the whole
notion of um delineating defense from
offense just collapses onto itself so
for instance if you think about a a
counter battery radar for artillery for
instance something like that A system
that would detect incoming fire and then
triangulate to know where that fire is
coming from and that is coupled with you
know some effector that would take down
the incoming munition and some other
effector that might be able to reach
that targets so see where I'm getting at
like you have that data the question is
like what do I do with the data and if I
feed it into that other system that
would then immediately launch like uh
maybe an artillery shell or something to
destroy uh the point of of you know
origin from where the from where the the
this you know weapon was fired at you
like what kind of system is it it's in
is it is it automatic defense or are you
already on the offense there so it's not
really clear that we can delineate it
this way and it's also in terms of you
know blurry lights and delineations this
is super important the thing that to
point it
out there is strictly speaking and I'm
saying this like technically speaking
there is no such thing as autonomous
weapon systems as a fixed category of
weapon systems we are not able and we
will not be able to delineate this fixed
category of autonomous weapon systems
from the nonautonomous weapon systems
that's that renders the whole thing
quite different from many other fields
where we did arms control or
humanitarian disarm like I can give you
you know list of criteria that will
pretty clearly delineate what an
anti-personal land mine is and you can
then quite easily distinguish it from an
anti-tank mine or an assault rifle or a
nuclear weapon whereas autonomy weapon
systems is just it's a function it can
be a feature of almost any conceivable
weapon system and any weapon system can
be autonomous now and now I flip the
switch and now it's back to remotely
piloted and you will never be able to
tell from the outside looking at it what
is it
you know I can see that's an
anti-personal landmine that's a nuclear
warhead this is just some ground robot I
don't know is it autonomous is it
selecting and engaging targets without
human intervention I don't know we will
never know by looking at it from the
outside which makes it super hard in
terms of formulating Regulation doing
arms control like if I were to say let's
cap the number of autonomous ground
robots at 300 and you build 300
additional of the same robots and you
tell me well those are remotely ped how
would I be able to verify this I hope it
gets clear this is where it's a bit more
complicated than other things that we've
dealt with in the past and it's
important to make that first step and
wrap your head around the fact that this
is this is about functionality and about
basically um rules in terms of
application rather than prohibitions or
limits on specific categories of web
okay so if we think at the at The
Cutting Edge which autonomous systems
are under development which systems
worry you the most that's an excellent
question there's two ways to answer this
on the one hand technology is increasing
the capabilities potentially of weapon
systems uh at an
amazing Pace that is the worrying
part the part that gives me rest some
faint rest hope is that militaries are
inherently conservative
organizations and especially Western
militaries that try to be at least uh
compliant with International regulations
and norms and and the law of War are
quite reluctant to be using this just to
see what happens basically so if we talk
about certification validation and
actually procuring a weapon system with
autonomy and then getting it into the
hands of operators and them using it
this is a very long
process and I would not be able to point
to one specific system other than the
ones that I've already mentioned that
that we've had for like 20 30 years
where autonomy is featuring in very
heavily uh in a in one of those rools
that we're imagining like for instance
um something like a loitering munition
or some uh some quad corer that you
could be using against enemy Personnel
so for instance if you if you look at
the a great resource to gauge where
we're at is always to look at ads and um
if you look at for instance I think it's
Albert the Israeli um company they're
making something like slaughterbots
basically you know the slaughterbots
video that that I'm pretty sure that fli
you know produced and I'm pretty sure
most people know depicted this dystopian
future where you have like
anti-personnel
mini drones buzzing around killing
people by you know slamming into their
heads
and lanus the system that I'm thinking
of right now is kind of like that in
that it is a quad cure that will go into
buildings it will map the building it
will find people it will track people
and it is you know R in a manner that
you be able to engage that Target that
person and kill it but it's interesting
to look at the ad and the ad shows that
there's an operator and the operator is
authorizing the engagement of the target
it's like a pre-election is happening
that the system will basically radio
back and say hey operator I found a
possible Target is it okay for me to
engage that Target and then the human is
you know basically making an assessment
and saying yes that is an enemy fighter
rather rather than one of our guys or
some civilian Engage The Target that is
super interesting to me why because it
it shows kind of this proton Norm is
already working like people are already
kind of hesitant about fully automating
this entire kill chain there's no reason
not to be doing it from a technical
perspective be easy the system is
detecting something that you know with
86.3% it presumes is an enemy combatant
why not have it you know go all the way
it turns out we're quite reluctant to be
doing this this probably like an
interesting research project to approach
these companies and talk to them and
find out like why are you not doing it
it it turns out that there's not a lot
of demand like when you talk to Industry
people they will say we could be doing
it for sure we're not doing it because
our customers are hesitant they don't
really want that and that tells me like
there's already something at work like
um nobody's rushing into this at least
responsible people I think are still
hesitant about rushing into this because
they know so many things could be going
wrong with it when the Drone is
pre-selecting a target it must have some
uh think some decision process in there
perhaps we could imagine and I I don't
know if this is a reality now or will
ever become a reality but we could
imagine a a set of of images of faces
and a drone authorized to to find those
faces in a in a in war zone and then
present those those uh enemies uh for a
a human evaluator who then makes the
final decision but you know as as you
yourself have written about there is
a in the pre-selection there's also uh
decisions going on exactly and so I
think this is a perfect point in time to
say the system that you've described
that would be on my prohibition list so
I mean so far I think I've not really
you know come out as someone who's like
ban Killer Robots simply because I think
B Killer Robots still is you know good
idea but simply because of the way um we
as a as a global Community have learned
about the way this technology is De
developing and the way that we want to
formulate some regulation around it we
found out that just coming out and
saying this is the the category of
weapons that we want to prohibit is
doing the work in this case however what
you've described is fairly clear to me
as something that should Simply Be
prohibited so it should not be brought
into the world the slaughterbots
basically this the system where you have
a biometric Target signature that says
all the white people in the room all the
female persons on the street all the
people with long hair whatever with a
certain gate whatever you want to you
know put in there that is purely uh a
weapon of Oppression and a weapon to
terrorize people with i' say i' i' go as
far as to say there is no
military value even in in having these
kinds of weapons because this is the
militaries militaries fight not like at
least we did for the longest time and
then you know we started targeting indiv
ual people with drones and so over the
last 20 years obviously a lot of you
know has shifted in that regard but
generally speaking you would be fighting
combatants and it's not relevant if this
is if this is combatant G Docker or some
other person it is just a
combat and so I think we we'd be we'd be
well advis to not be even building and
you know fielding and using weapons that
look for specific biometric Target
signatures to kill people with because
you know that gets into the wrong hands
and we will have all kinds of you know
um
trouble um that would be the pro the
prohibition part and and this is
basically International Committee of the
Red Cross
talking they have laid this out quite
clearly and they said this is definitely
the one thing that we should not be
doing full stop and all the other things
have to do with meaningful human control
and other things that I'm sure we will
get to in this conversation but that's
something this notion of killing
individual people by facial recognition
that's just awful and is this a
fundamental limit of the technology or
could we could we Imagine A system that
is so capable and and so precise that
that we might be interested in in
allowing it so imagine that this system
I I described came to you a a military
decision maker and told you I am
97% sure that I have a person here who's
who's the leader of a terrorist
organization uh do you want to kill this
person is so is it is it a is it a
fundamental limit or is it is it about
the technology being too brittle for us
to to employ it in the way that I've
describe several things to unpack I mean
if if we were to automate this and say
at the 97%
threshold weapon system um if you at
this threshold just engage I I'd say we
are in this you know territory that I
described before where I would say we
shouldn't be going there if you have a
system that is looking if for specific
individuals and you want to say this is
the general of the you know enemy armed
forces and we think we have found him we
have some sensors buzzing around there
and it tells me you know 97% and I have
a couple of other people and maybe I
have some signals intelligence also that
would corroborate this then I think
we're you know fairly clearly back in
the realm of just War fighting where you
would be authorizing a strike on that
Target but you've you have some you had
some you had some human judgment in
there you had humans looking at this
you're controlling the selection NE
Target is made by humans and they
hopefully have done their best to also
you know get additional data on this
rather than just saying tells me 97%
this is the guy that the other thing
really is and this is where it gets like
quite interesting from from an ethical
and legal point of view if we were to
build the perfect killing machine which
is just perfect at everything it it will
always know who's a combatant who's a
civilian it will never misfire it will
do all the right things it will function
perfectly 100% IHL compliant should we
be using it or some would say aren't we
then you know under the obligation to
use it to be more IHL compliant should
we then just take all the rifles away
from the stupid monkey humans they who
are making so many mistakes and just let
the machines do all the
killing and this is really the question
where this quick silvery notion of human
dignity comes in and where especially I
as a German we have this as the first
article in our basic law our
constitution human is about human
dignity where I get like really caught
feet I do know that we basically um
again differentiate at this point
between Kanan people and European
Continental philosophy and then
utilitarians so if I speak to maybe even
you know British American
friends even they they they' be like I
don't get your point Frank if the system
is better we should be using the system
like it it will give us an advantage
less innocent people will be killed what
is your problem now the problem would be
maybe from a legal point of view we stop
having a an issue with the system if it
works perfectly as described because
then it will be able to fulfill all the
legal obligations however if we automate
killing in this manner so that we're not
even concerning ourselves anymore with
who one when and where is getting killed
in war are we just infringing on the
human dignity of the people we kill
because we reduce them to Anonymous data
points in some you know ginormous
killing machinery and you know we do
know what happens if we dehumanize
people if we make them into just a bunch
of numbers or if we give them animal
names or stuff like that so as I said
there's a good reason due to our history
in Germany why we have this at as the
first rule of our basic law that human
dignity must not and cannot be infringed
on on ever and so this is really another
thing that gives me pause where I'd say
I'm not against using autonomy but we
should still concern ourselves with what
is happening in war and rather than
decoupling ourselves from it completely
which is quite dangerous in in in
Democratic Society specifically because
we are risk averse we are casualty
averse and we've seen politically
speaking where we end up if we
completely remove the human from the
equation uh for instance by only be
using drones ing missiles from the sky
and you know no longer having any
meaningful skin in the game and I don't
mean we do have to be producing body
bags I mean we should be concerning
ourselves with what is happening in war
rather than just you know pushing a
button in the morning and then at the
end of the day you know looking at a
readout which tells us you know the 16
targets that were engaged at point that
seems quite dystopian to me okay to what
extent do you think autonomy in in
Weapons Systems is analogous to to
nuclear weapons so so we've already
discussed two uh ways in which these
systems are
disanalogous um first of all nuclear
weapons are fairly discreet in a way
that autonomy is isn't and and also um
nuclear weapons simply kill many more
people at once you you can imagine
perhaps swarms of autonomous weapon
systems um killing as many people but
but nuclear weapons seem seem more
destructive for a one-time use if you
think in more broad terms how how are a
how is autonomy in in weapon
systems analgous and disanalogous to to
nuclear weapons I think it's way more
dis analogous than it is analogous I
think in many respects it is the
opposite and I know that the for
instance there's there's some people who
frame uh you know autonomy in we weapon
systems especially when we talk about
swarms as a weapon of mass destruction I
think that is a great mistake I think it
makes no sense conceptually speaking
because autonomy weapon systems if we
once again you know go to the slaughter
B notion are kind of the exact opposite
of what nuclear weapons are is are doing
you know nuclear weapons kill huge
amounts of people
indiscriminately almost in an instant
whereas like small autonomous qu Ops
buzzing around killing individual people
and only those people due to some
biometric Target profile that seems to
me like the opposite of indiscriminate
it is highly discriminate it may just be
it may just as well be uh you know
against all International humanitarian
law and maybe just as well a war crime
but it's just not the same thing it's
the some the thing the actual thing that
happens the killing is completely
different so that that would be my one
point and also you know I've ranted
about this uh already at length I can
clearly differentiate a nuclear weapon
from any other
weapon a dirty bomb is not a nuclear
weapon a chemical weapon or a biological
weapon or Conventional Weapons are not
nuclear
weapon autonomy weapon systems as I said
you know it's this functionality that is
just you know in there or maybe or maybe
not and that we just have to you know
wrestle with to be able to use it in a
in a responsible manner it's just not
the same thing
and so also which gets us to regulation
you know I I have a background like my
PhD was on nuclear weapons on nuclear
use basically why did we never use
nuclear weapons uh after
1945 you know lots of opportunities
certainly enough weapons to go around so
we could have but we didn't and so you
know there's deterrence and there's the
nuclear taboo and all kinds of things
that you be could be talking about uh in
that regard and also we did arms control
and we were able to do specific things
like cap numbers prohibit specific types
of weapons and we were able to clearly
Define them and count
them and again this is just something
that we can't do in with regard to
autonomy we so we we need to find new
ways of doing arms control rather in a
qualitative rather than quantitative
manner it doesn't make sense to talk
about proliferation in the same way that
we talk about proliferation for nuclear
weapons in in the in the case of of of
autonomy in Weapons Systems then correct
yes I mean the the notion of
proliferation is a term I think that was
you know drawn from biology and from
cancer research where you have like
cancer cells one cancer cell that is
then proliferating in in terms of like
it's spreading cancer at specific points
in the body you will then find Body uh
cancer in in the liver for instance
where it wasn't before and so it it goes
from one point to other distinct points
that would be a good an analogy to
nuclear weapons because this is the way
if we think of the AQ cam Network for
instance the Pakistani Network that's
spread weapons technology it's like one
source of origin one or maybe two points
where something ends up and autonomy
weapon systems obviously is not like
this at all it is software uh you can
it's copyable at almost no cost you can
throw it into an existing technological
ecosystem where you already have
basically robots
things that sense things that act and so
you just put in additional software that
if you have to compute in the
system um the system can do more perform
more more functions than it could before
and you don't need any you don't need to
be mining uranium or you don't need
nuclear reactors and yeah it's just much
much easier and so I speak of Technology
diffusion rather than proliferation
because it just diffuses from every
conceivable Point does it make sense to
talk about escalation or an arms race
for autonomy in Weapons Systems then
that is a hard question it's way harder
than you think uh because we've we've
gotten so used to be using the term arms
race I I fully understand why people are
using it because there is clearly a rush
towards more technology that in the end
might enable autonomy in weapon systems
in in militaries around the globe right
so you know civil military Fusion
sometimes it's called so for instance
the Pentagon will have offices in
Silicon Valley to talk to startups hey
what are you doing what is what is the
research you're doing what are you doing
with uh deep learning are there maybe
products that we could be using that we
could be like really quickly integrated
into into our own Innovation
cycle China's doing the exact same thing
Russia's trying to do it so clearly
there is a run towards this because
everybody feels like this is like the
step from away from the horse to the
internal combustion engine this is just
the new engine that will power every
we're doing and so we need to be really
fast to be adopting it because our
competitors you might be overtaking us
and so there is this there is a race
going on that is correct however if you
look at the you know the political
science definition of what an arser is
and you look at for instance at things
like overspending I don't really see
that if you look at for instance again
example from Germany um after the
Russian invasion in Ukraine in 20122 we
decided to spend a00 billion euros on
our military and we're not
buying autonomous St we're buying
fighter
planes chips like basic military stuff
and and so if you were to say are we in
an arms phace like the cold war arms
race where we're overspending and we're
just you know spending two% of our GDP
just to build additional nuclear
warheads that we don't need we're not in
that kind of arms race maybe in Brackets
yet but at least we're not in that now
but there's clearly this this rush and
this sense of urgency around the globe
where militaries are thinking we got to
get into this because this is the next
thing having said that I don't know how
deep we want to go into all all all
these kind of things it is a an endless
rock paper scissor game and so you might
be saying okay now we have all these you
know autonomous drones Bing around doing
things well maybe some chicken fence or
maybe some other you know already
existing quite um Simple Technology
might be able to counter this very
effectively on the battlefield and then
you're back to square one and all your
high-tech and all your deep learning
maybe didn't even do that much that
that's another thing we don't really
know for sure like how big the impact is
because nobody
has like really started using it in a
manner that is really increasing
military Effectiveness in a broader
scope and so we also don't know about
how easy it might be to to fool and to
trick and to develop counters against it
that's another thing that I I think is
maybe part of this rush or this race
that we're not putting enough thought
into how this might be um quite a
foolish Endeavor in terms of we're over
we're spending billions and billions of
dollars to train neuron Nets to do this
that and the other um assuming that we
will be of course be able to you know uh
defeat the enemy with that but enemy the
enemy isn't stupid maybe they come up
with something quite clever and quite
easy to just make all this multi-billion
dollar effort um useless uh with the
with the chicken wire fence is that an
actra possibility that that we might be
able to to stop or or or defeat
autonomous systems W with something as
simple as a chicken wi fence yeah I mean
slaughterbots uh the slaughterbots video
to me I was like who some chicken fans
boom problem solved you know what I mean
yeah although you you equip it with some
actuators and it cuts a hole in the
chicken fence you could you could you
could see how I mean now we just talked
about race Dynamics you would you would
probably see a response from from from
the developers of of these autonomous
systems pretty pretty quickly yeah for
sure but but that's what I meant it's
rock paper scissor and it's just it
keeps on going and that you know I will
have to come up with uh with some system
maybe some later that would blind those
things or whatever and this is just how
it goes there's this concept of
entanglement um between Conventional
Weapons and weapons with more autonomy
what does this mean so the the the
notion of entanglement is originally one
where people became aware of the fact
that there are specific dual use assets
that um are relevant to both
conventional War fighting and nuclear
operations satellites would be the prime
example if you were to destroy large
parts of the US military satellite
Network that would be a huge problem for
them to conduct conventional operations
but it would also have an impact on
their nuclear space awareness all these
kind of things you know early warning
etc etc and so people were like oof um
we've got these duol use assets and now
we have Conventional
Weapons because of specific Technologies
um that have developed over the last
couple of decades and drones would be
one of those things but also um know
cruise missiles and neuro rocket
technology um hyper velocity projectiles
all these kind of things we have this
tool use as and they're now more
vulnerable to Conventional Weapons
whereas you know in the in the past you
would have to drop a nuke on this
basically now you can very precisely
maybe Target this with a conventional
weapon so you're not really initiating a
nuclear exchange but you're targeting
parts of the nuclear infrastructure of
your adversary and so that's where the
idea of entanglement came from that
people were saying O we have now where
before we had this bright line between
conventional war and then you know the
red line
where we step over into um nuclear war
that is getting kind of blurry because
of the way technology is developing in
also the way that Doctrine has um
developed over the last couple of years
and decades and so yeah you can easily
see again how autonomy might just put
steroids into this you know because you
have maybe you have you know uncrewed
weapon systems doing things and now
they're doing them faster without being
remotely piloted anymore that might some
people you know give some people pause
and think oof what about my Nuclear
assets you know one of the one of the
ideas that is being kicked around I'm
pretty um skeptical about it but just to
give you an idea what people are talking
about it's this notion of the
transparent ocean right so um the best
way from a nuclear Powers perspective to
keep your nuclear weapons so that you
have a uh credible uh second strike
capabilities to put them in into
submarines and then have them submerged
so nobody knows where they are and
whenever you're attacked you can always
you know fire back so you have this
credible threat of being able to retell
it and so if everything works out
fine then the first strike will never
really materialize but if you have like
thousands and thousands of you know
submerged sensor networks and just
drones autonomously buzzing through the
oceans looking for everything with I
don't know Quantum magnetometers
measuring like tiny
uh tiny changes in the earth uh magnetic
field all of a sudden um the ocean might
might become transparent that's the the
ocean that is being ground transparent
ocean and then your second strike uh
capability is all of a sudden gone
because you know your submarine might be
a Target when the enemy decides to
launch that first strike and here here
we can see how in tanglement is is you
have to spill over from the conventional
realm into nuclear thinking and that is
of course it's not it's not good it's
just a an additional source of
instability would nuclear facilities on
the ground also be exposed potentially
to autonomous systems or be be
threatened by by new autonomous
systems potentially yes I
mean we've had this conversation quite
specifically I remember that I maybe 10
years ago the Russians were quite um
unhappy with the way the unru systems
development in the US was and they were
like what if you're developing something
like a conventional First Strike weapon
where you go
into um into this first strike with all
kinds of precision guided Munitions um
swarms of drones and and um cruise
missiles to basically disarm our
landbased component and destroy all our
silos and the road mobile icbms aren't
you just you know doing terrible things
to nuclear stability so we have this
conversation for a fact actually I'm not
sure like how much paranoia is in there
because I have a hard time of you know
conceiving a scenario where that
actually works and and where anybody
would be insane enough to do something
like this but we at least we we're
having these these conversations are
happening for real and this is something
that nuclear Powers think about what do
you think the world looks like if we
have unregulated diffusion of uh
autonomous systems what what's the
relevance of more traditional military
assets how how safe does the public feel
um yeah what does the world look like I
remember I I was uh in in Geneva at the
United Nations couple of years ago I try
to remember which year it was exactly
was before the pandemic maybe 2017 18
something like this and we were in that
room the convention on certain
Conventional Weapons uh room talking
autonomous uh talking autonomy weapon
systems and Russia has always been like
quite the spoiler State there they they
would for years and years they would be
saying we don't even know why we should
be talking about this there is no issue
here in existing international law is
enough and this is basically all all of
this what you're talking about is
science
fiction and a journalist approached me
and she was saying yeah just flew in
from Moscow we were at an Arms Fair have
you seen this thing and she saw showed
me on her on her uh smartphone a video
that they took at the armare in Moscow
where Kalashnikov and you can look that
up it's on YouTube they have an ad up
where Kalashnikov was presenting a
turret with an with the object
recognition system basically which would
look for silhouett of people or or a
truck and then open
fire and I mean that was quite jarring
basically the Russian delegation saying
we don't even know what you're talking
about and you know Kalashnikov at the
same time selling this turet with which
selects engages and engages targets
without human Intervention which is
which is an autonomous weapon system
firing at basically the Silhouettes of
people of human beings and so your
question is like what would the world
look like well if we were to be Fielding
these kinds of weapons we would
basically kiss goodby International
humanitarian law
because never ever in a million years no
I'm not going to say never ever because
you know chat gbt all kinds of things
gener generative AI all kinds of things
are happening dramatically fast so I
don't know where technology is taking us
but for now let's say for now and the
foreseeable future I have no doubt that
this Kalashnikov system or its
predecessor um would never be able to
work in in an IHL compliant manner
because it would have to be able to
recognize is this a combatant is this a
civilian what is this combatant doing is
the combatant wound wounded is he trying
to surrender all these kind of things
that machines are not capable of at the
moment and if we if we were to tell them
well if the you know if you know this
combatant is waving a white flag and
tries to surrender don't fire then I'd
say great let's all you know get a white
flag and then you
know just overrun the enemy because all
the weapon systems wouldn't be firing
because machines are D this is what
worries me it's not like the
intelligence it's in the systems it's
how dumb these systems are and yes
people make mistakes but we don't make
all the same mistake at the same time at
lightning speed and so stupid machines
making terrible mistakes at lightning
speed that is what worries and um so a
world where we're just you know
proliferating no diffusing uh this into
every corner of the world and
everybody's using it I would say IHL
will be a real problem and the other
thing escalation you know you could
easily imagine something like this just
C cascading out of control just some
sensor Network sensing something maybe
it's a mistake we we've had this with in
the nuclear realm you know with the sun
glints on on cloud covers or Gees flock
of these that satellites would pick up
and say there's an there's there's a
launch in Russia uh or you know vice
versa and all these near misses that we
had because we were relying on sensor
systems and automated systems that would
tell us what to do and if we just you
know automate this all through and
selection and engagement of targets is
just across the board feature of
everything that we're doing then we
could be in a shooting War triggered by
machines um quite quickly and nobody
would be fast enough to be pulling the
plug and so this this these would be
just two things that really give me
concern where I would say not saying we
shouldn't be using autonomy but we need
to be like real careful about it how do
you think autonomy changes the Power
Balance between states so here I'm
thinking does it make it easier for
states with traditionally weaker
militaries to to defend or or engage
states with uh with stronger traditional
militaries I think so um again I think
Ukraine is demonstrating this um the way
they've been using uh drones for Sr and
for a targeting purposes um clearly
shows intelligence surveillance
reconnaissance yeah it would be
basically the first part of the
targeting cycle the finding fixing
tracking um they're doing this um and
they are you know successfully beating
back uh um uh on paper at least you know
uh much more a bigger fighting force
let's say you know what this does to the
balance of power generally speaking or
you know if we zoom out is quite
unclear to be to be honest I wouldn't
venture to guess at this point because
of what I was saying before we're we're
still which is a good thing because it
gives us you know some more time to
think about this and to put up some
guard rails but we're still at the cusp
of this I wouldn't be you know um
prognosticating in terms of well if
China does this and that then in 10
years
stable it's quite unclear also because
of the fact that like I said some of
those things for instance loitering
Munitions right that but that would be
something that you you deploy it goes up
in the air it hangs around it loiters
waits for 20 minutes 30 minutes maybe an
hour looks for a specific Target
signature say a leopard to main battle
tank right it finds this thing it has an
object recognition it sees this sees the
target it says you know we're back to
the 997 % says that's 97% you know I'm
sure that's a leopard two and not a
School Bus full of children and so let's
let's just say it it is autonomous in
the critical function so the system goes
okay selected engage and it dive bombs
into the tank and these things
are nasty we've seen this in nagoro
kabak and we're now seeing it in Ukraine
like
um the especially the Russians have you
know um ramped up production of these
Lauder munitions and they are terrible
for Ukrainian armor 5 years from now
every fighting force will have some sort
of short range air defense so you know
turrets maybe lasers may maybe you know
10 years from now microwave Beams I
don't know should just shoot these
things down if everything goes according
to let's say plan or the way these
things usually go then this threat for
for heavy armor on the battlefield right
now will have stopped being a threat in
5 to 10 years because we will have
developed counter marar against this and
so if you look at it from the autonomy
perspective you would be saying well
these autonomous lawyering Munitions
they are terrible they're making the
tank
Obsolete and I'm like no they're not
give it five years and the tank will
have some system going and then you know
this La munition will be gone and it
won't probably won't be an issue
probably that turret will be autonomous
the crew in that tank will probably not
even you know be dealing with this it
will be looking the tank will be looking
for these kinds of Munitions and it will
autonomously defending against them and
the crew will be safe and the tank will
be just you know doing tank things so
we're using autonomy to defend against
the enemy's autonomy do you think is
this a positive development can we avoid
the arms race by developing counter
autonomy systems maybe I'm not smart
enough to see how we would be avoiding
the arms race it's like if we were to
avoid the arms race then there would be
a point where the rock paper scissor
Dynamic just stops and I don't see it
stopping because that loing munition
that will be shot down by the autonomous
turret on the tank that won't be around
for long and then there will be loing Ms
that probably go into a wild
zigzag when diving down and to avoid the
autonomous turret and then they will be
useful again and then something else
will come along and you know I I wish
we'd be spend spending all that money
that we spend on the lawyerings and the
turret on Healthcare or a million other
things but I talk to people in the
industry as well and they will tell me
we need autonomy to defend against
autonomy this is already going on and
like I said we had we have had autonomy
in those turrets and these defensive
systems shooting at incoming stuff for
decades and now you know some of the
cruise missiles and many of the missiles
the missiles always were are getting
faster and faster
Hypersonic you don't have a lot of time
to decide and so people will tell me we
need to automate the entire thing just
to be able to defend against all this
incoming munition stuff that is on the
horizon what I was thinking was
defending against lering attacks from
above with autonomy in in these tank uh
systems that that seems like a like a
defensive use and and a more positive
use of of autonomy now of course we can
go back to our your earlier point about
uh defensive defensive technology
quickly becoming offensive technology
and so that distinction maybe isn't as
meaningful but what I was thinking was
whether we could defend against
autonomous systems using autonomy but in
a way that doesn't uh provoke the enemy
or or uh push this arms race further
yeah I I guess so yeah I mean here's the
thing I had to quite the learn curve as
I said I I started catching wind of this
in 2007 it's now 16 years
later uh I look at stuff that I wrote
maybe five to six years ago I throw my
hands up in the air and I'm like why did
I over complicate this you know it's a
functional thing you've got to look at
this from a functional perspective and
it's who or what human or machine is
selecting and engaging so it took me a
while it took all of us a while it took
the the International Community at the
UN a while to get there but the way that
we're talking about this now uh is I
think the level of differentiation that
we should be having when we when we have
this conversation because yeah I mean
this autonomous tarret which is only and
solely and obviously you know tanks have
automated protective systems like Trophy
and so on and so forth that Al also
already exists you know systems that
would engage an incoming you know RPG
cutting it in half in the air before
even reaches the tank that already
exists so we're not talking about sci-fi
stuff that hasn't happened yet that that
is already in existence it would just be
you know further developing these kinds
of systems like trophy 2.0 which would
be know good against lawyer
ammunitions and so like I said the level
of differentiation that we should be
having is what is a use that is IHL
compliant that is not getting us into
hot water from an ethical perspective
that is not infringing on human dignity
if we're shooting down loing Munitions
like no one's human dignity is involved
here and which is also not accelerating
Battlefield Tempo to a point where we're
you know losing control of what is
happening on the battlefield what the
Chinese called battlefield Singularity
like where just the machines keep
fighting and we don't even know what
happens anymore and I would say like
this turret this hypothetical turret
against Ling ammunitions on the main
battle tank I think that that satisfies
all those criteria and that is why I'm
saying I'm not against autonomic weapon
systems per se I'm for a responsible
manner of using them and for good guard
rails um in terms of meaningful human
control don't use them to Target
individual people by facial recognition
or biometric signatures and don't for
piz build weapons like this Kalashnikov
thing that are just you know never able
to comply with IHL because there's no
meaningful human control in there at all
they just fire at whatever looks vaguely
like a human so again back to the to the
chicken wire fence what are the
prospects of Defending against autonomy
by using dumb and cheap uh Solutions so
there there's the chicken wire fence but
I could also imagine perhaps putting
masks on soldiers that are that make it
so that you can't do facial recognition
that that that that seems like a very
cheap solution I have no idea whether it
would actually work but Solutions like
that what do you think of of that kind
of solution
we should Workshop your idea um I don't
know if it works but um I think it goes
back to this whole notion of the enemy
also like has a say and a good anecdote
I think um in this um regard is the
surch in Iraq in 200 I think six I'm not
sure when the US just you know um went
into specific cities with much more
force and the way they did that is or at
least tried for a while is they send in
like round robots and those robots they
had a machine gun and a camera and they
were rolling rolling in there and what
those things effectively did is give
machine guns and ammunition to the enemy
from a US perspective because obviously
the insurgents weren't Dum um and
obviously they just you know snuck away
and hit while this thing was rolling by
and then you know they went behind it
kicked it over took the machine gun took
all the ammunition and you know went
their way and so this notion of wow
we're automating all these things and
we're using robots and now we're putting
all kinds of object recognition and you
know machine learning techniques into
them and that will make it so much
better as I said that could be a Fool's
erand and so when we're talking about
autonomy and selection engagement of
targets I'm drawing an analogy to uh
self-driving cars where I'm not sure if
that is still the case but whenever ever
I check up on it it is still the case
which I find insane and that is that I'm
not naming specific manufacturers now
but there's one company that makes
self-driving cars and they're quite
Advanced the object recognition system
the computer vision system in that car
last time I checked you know even those
very sophisticated um systems are still
being fooled by very very simple
countermeasures um such as a bit of
reflective tape stuck onto a stop sign
any human being would still be easily be
able to say that's a stop sign is some
tape is on there but it's a stop sign uh
whereas the system you know uh is
tricked by it and you know stumbles and
is no longer able to recognize the stop
sign as a stop sign which is uh there's
a term for it that is adversarial image
insertion and so I'm thinking about this
now and say okay if those self-driving
cars that are potentially in a future
you know um moving around in a friendly
ecosystem all of them talking to each
other maybe even them talking to EnV to
the environment and you know if making
them work is so
hard how hard will it be to make your
system work in an in an environment that
is not friendly that is not Cooperative
that has agents in there that will do
whatever they can to trick you fool you
and do all these kind of things and so
I'm thinking um probably we're moving
into a future where you are just you
have a 3D printer I wrote a short story
on this where basically um there's a
couple of soldiers they're in a forest
and they they they have an armored
vehicle and it looks kind of weird the
one guy says why does it look so weird
and he says yeah we have this three
printed stuff that we glued on there
it's just count like really quick and
dirty it's just some knobs and stuff and
it makes the vehicle look
weird um and they found out that the the
Laing Munitions and the drones buzzing
overhead of the enemy are now no longer
recognizing this thing as what it is so
it trips up the the algorithm basically
and they're now safe from the spying
eyes of the enemy it's just a story but
it this is it goes to show that maybe we
will be moving into a future where you
can find pretty easy solutions just to
fool the system to trick it and to no
longer trigger the 97% certainty that
this is a target maybe it you know like
we know from this image recognition
business it says this is a snowplow it's
a snow plow it's a snow blow it's a cat
why did it say cat these examples are
all examples of of adversarial input and
what you see with autonomous cars or
self self-driving cars is that when they
when they encounter some image or some
input that didn't exist uh wasn't
repeated a lot of times in training data
they will be tripped up so you can
imagine for example a self-driving car
in a in a carnival on the street a kind
of festival with people in costumes well
how many times have have have a
self-driving car encountered a a pink
rabbit a person in a in in a pink rabbit
costume probably not that many times and
that that could trip it up and you could
you could see as you described you could
see how that could be used on the
battlefield with with uh autonomous uh
weapon system so perhaps uh perhaps you
give your your vehicle some pattern that
you know trips up the enemy's system or
more bleakly perhaps you can glue that
pattern on on the enemy's uh vehicle or
station and so have have the enemy
autonomous systems attack the enemy
itself basically so so an instance of
Friendly Fire it it sounds to me like
you think this is this is pretty likely
I'm pretty likely I don't know um but
it's definitely I think something that
we should be aware of and there's not a
lot of people thinking about this it's
like all the political and Military
discourse is on this will be great we
will be using this and it will give us
these fantastic
advantages and I'm like maybe but you
know think one step further what might
an adversary be doing so red team this
and yeah I can I can you know I can
think of scenarios like this where
you'll be able to counter with fairly
simple measures something that cost a
billion dollars to develop and it just
evaporates in terms of Effectiveness and
just doesn't doesn't work the way it's
intended yeah and I think I think you
made an important Point by saying
that in a in a war uh situation we're
we're dealing with an enemy that's
thinking very hard about how to trip up
our systems and what we see with our
kind of everyday uh you know with our
self-driving cars is that they're
tripped up by by situations that are not
uh where there isn't some intelligent
adversary trying to trip it up it's just
being tripped up by by the random
effects of of everyday life I mean PE
people are getting like really creative
in war like um one thing that the
Russians are doing in the Mine Fields uh
is just to um stack mines three on top
of each other so that when the m
clearing equipment gets in which is you
know not designed to clear basically
like one mine at a time to eat it up and
absorb the force and then just keep
rolling they just blow up the the those
plows that they use to plow the
Minefield because they stack the mines
and well now what it's a super simple
solution and you but you've stopped the
enemy in in in in this case the Ukraine
are the enemy from the Russian point of
view you stop them literally in their
tracks just by St nobody thought of this
apparently yet and and I'm just saying
like this is the way it works people are
inventive around these things what about
cyber attacks on autonomous systems
you've written about manipulating GPS
data for example how how feasible do you
think that is well we should be careful
at this point because I mean in a way
autonomy
is Pursuit because you're less
susceptible to cyber attacks the the
idea of um having a weapon system that
could also be operating autonomously in
terms of also selecting and engaging
targets without human intervention is
for the system to be capable to fulfill
the mission even though uh even when the
connection to the operator is severed so
in that sense autonomy gives you um this
comfortable situation where having a
command and control link is optional so
in that sense if you if you have a
system that is also navigating not only
with GPS data but but also in terms of
for instance you know electrooptical
sensors or maybe again something with
the you know Quantum magnetometers I'm
sorry but I recently you know looked
into those and I was like wow this is
interesting so theyve they've Advanced
um quite substantially over the P couple
of years so if you give it additional
points of data to work with and to be
able to navigate then it wouldn't be a
problem if the GPS signal is either
denied to the system or if there's a
spof going on that's something that you
can also do you can feed it GPS data
that's wrong and to make it think that
it's places where it isn't and maybe
even also like you know land in a
country where it's not supposed to land
and stuff like supposedly like one of
the very high very um um you know secret
us drones has been um captured by Iran
this way just by speeding it wrong GPS
info so it went down someplace where the
Iranians could recover it but
um yeah um it it depends one of the key
Notions really is to have autonomy in
there not to be U having to rely on GPS
and other things but obviously feeding
it feeding the system with spoof data or
just you know for instance images like
we were talking about before that is
something that would trip it up in a way
that only an autonomous system would
trip up and and cyber yeah just to say
cyber the same thing basically if that
system is completely you know sealed off
and just operating on its own and
there's no communication going in and
out you won't be you won't be having any
cyber you know issue then unless you've
compromised it beforehand in some shape
or form you know and you know you know
fed with the software the firmware or
something so that when something
specific happens something is triggered
in the system but um yeah this is not
necessarily like in terms of an attack
against the system from the outside when
it's out there operating doing stuff
yeah yeah in in cyber security if you
want to make something very secure you
you isolate it from the world you make
it impossible to to uh extract
information about it or to feed it
information but if you you can see how
that just wouldn't work for for autonomy
or for autonomous weapons because they
they need that this data to to to
function and to navigate you've written
about un the unpredictability of
autonomous systems uh this is this is
this introduces another complexity
around how potentially autonomous
systems are perceived by the enemy so we
imagine a a drone or a robot coming
towards you and you don't know whether
this the system is autonomous what what
are the effects of that yeah the
unpredictability is what got I think
most of the technical folks into this
field um in the very beginning like it
seemed to me like my my background is in
political science as I said I've done a
lot of work on nuclear weapons I started
looking into Hightech Weaponry in the NS
and then you know 2007 autonomy all
these kinds of things but I look at it
from a political science strategic
stability Arms Control point of view and
the tech people they were like um most
of them they were like you can't be
serious like the technology is not
reliable enough to be used in this kind
of setting you know there's a reason
that for instance civil aviation is not
touching deep learning with a 10-ft PO
because this is not the way air you know
air travel safety Works they they don't
want any probabilistic systems in there
it needs to be like water type for them
99.8% is not good enough for civil
aviation and so the tech people were
like reliability and unpredictability
this is a huge problem for us that's why
we need to be because we with our
technical knowledge about how these
systems are actually built and how
neural Nets are trained and what they
can do and what they cannot do and what
we understand and do not understand
about them we need to be telling this to
the military people because when this
all started in 2010 2013 14 the military
seem to be like yeah this is amazing
this is the Silver Bullet we put we put
some magic AI Source into every weapon
system and then every everything will be
so much better and the tech people were
like no no the reliability and the
unpredictability um that will
like really come back and buite you
because for instance we have no idea how
your systems that you've trained on some
specific set of data would be
interacting with an enemy system trained
on data and we've seen this for instance
uh um at the financial markets with um
flash crashes where trading algorithms
just trip up and get into each other's
way or just encounter something on the
markets that they're just
misinterpreting kind of same with the
self-driving cars and then we have just
you know the British pound crashing down
and losing you know many P digits of its
value in percent be and and then usually
someone pulls the plug and just takes
this trading algorithm offline and if we
if we imagine the same thing just
algorithms um getting into each other's
hair uh then we have like and I
mentioned this before this notion of a
flash War like a shooting War being
triggered algorithmically and maybe in a
temple that we having a hard time to
stop it and to you know stop it
cascading through uh you know our entire
military apparatus in the end and the
these things surely I think um have been
discussed a lot over the last decade or
so and I can I can tell you one thing as
I said before like this C notion of
human dignity not a lot of people are
really sharing this at least not to the
same degree that like for instance I
would I wrote about this but this notion
of unpredictability of delegating
functions from humans to machines and
the machines performing those functions
automatically autonomously whatever you
want to call it and US losing control
this is widely shared as a big risk and
people know this in Beijing in Moscow in
Berlin in Brussels in Paris and in in
Washington wherever you want to go this
is what gives people the
creeps and so that that would be
especially in the time that we're living
in now like everything is quite
polarized and you know the international
situation is tense at the moment you
need to find specific um points of like
a common denominator like points of
convergence where everybody can at least
have a minuscule agreement on that on
where the problem might line and this is
I think where most people can agree on
that we're getting into potentially
strategic instability hot borders of the
way we've never seen it before if we're
rushing into this without the guard
rails and the the control mechanisms in
place and just automating things um that
then you know become runaway systems
that we can't um control anymore are we
likely to trust autonomous systems too
much so there's a there's this concept
of automation bias in which we we trust
the decisions of autonomous SS too much
so how much of a problem do you think
this is it's definitely a problem
because we've
seen um the results of it um I mentioned
this before in 2003 a US Patriot battery
in Iraq um shot down two friendly
airplanes an F-18 and a I think tornado
British tornado and an F-18 uh us F-18
in the end there's a great report on
this by a person written by a person who
knows the Patriot missile defense system
better than probably any other person on
the planet and he says that he was not
surprised by this um because the problem
that you're dealing with is you have
this you know crew of operators
operating that system and it's 23 hours
59 minutes and 59 seconds of total utter
boredom and then there's this one second
of sheer Terror where you need to be
deciding what to
do and you will be under a heavy
pressure to just do what the machine is
suggesting and that is automation bias
basically you've trained it and in all
the training Sim simulations the machine
was always right and you know you when
the light was green you pushed the
button to shoot down the the enemy
aircraft or or the enemy Scot missile
whatever you you know uh have and the
system works and it's great it is it is
a big problem um if we were to you know
be implementing this kind of automation
across the board in many many more
systems and there's no I probably
there's people who are experts on
automation buys and this you know the
ergonomics of human machine
interfacing I've I'm not an expert on
this like at all I've talked to people
who do this and who deal with this it
seems like there is no be all and all
solution to this but it is in the end a
question I think of
training and of yes I mean UI design and
basically trying to make the machine
talk to the human in a way that um makes
the whole human machine team less
susceptible to stuff like this but it's
definitely it is definitely a problem
and the the situation is also inherently
difficult even with the best uh UI
design and setup for for extracting the
the best decision- making from humans I
would say you I mean you're making
decisions uh with uncertain information
and under enormous time pressure as you
mentioned you may have maybe have a
minute to decide uh say the system you
know we we discussed 97% uh previously
say the system presents you with there a
97.25% probability that this is the
enemy now now you're you get the
impression that the system is much more
precise uh you think okay if it says
97256 then it's definitely not 40% but
yeah this would be an example of of bad
UI if if in fact as I would would say
it's it's overwhelmingly likely the
system is not that precise yeah what
what do we do about this if anything um
I mean the the the the approaches that I
have seen um that I found to be
perfectly honest a bit
underwhelming were that you know the
problem was discussed and people came in
and they were like we're going we're
going to be using expanable AI I was
like okay you know what does that entail
and you know the answer was heat Maps so
you would you would you would have an
object recognition system and it would
tell you 97% you know this is a S400 you
know enemy uh air defense system and
then you could basically push a button
and then the system would display a heat
map telling you which parts of that
picture it uses to come to this
conclusion so that the human looking at
this would then have maybe an
inclination of all it's drawing this
conclusion from looking at the trees in
the background you know this weird image
recognition stuff that that happens and
then you know the human maybe might be
able to say hm maybe it's not 97% maybe
this is just you know a lorry like a
truck with logs on it which kind of
looks like an S400 but the system got
confused and it's looking at the trees
stuff like this and I I was like if
that's you know the best we can do by
leveraging expand expandable AI showing
this kind of heat map I'm not sure like
we've really solved the problem um and
also one of the things that you know
people will always impress on me from
the military point of view is that don't
have time people in these situations do
not have time to look very carefully at
this heat map and you know take 30
seconds to think about this yeah we
don't we don't have it figured out the
only the only thing that I can say is
that this gives us all the more reason
to pump the brakes and not be rushing
into this and maybe come up with good
guard rails first before implementing
these these things and trying trying to
you know use them do you think that
humans will remain relevant to decision
making in over the long term do do you
think it'll it'll be important to keep a
human in the loop of of making these
life or death decisions because we're
discussing these systems as they exist
now presumably they'll they'll become
more advanced maybe it will take longer
than expected but at some point they
will probably be quite good H there are
are
of of life that that is automated now
and we would we wouldn't dream of of
having a a human do certain jobs now
over the long term should should humans
remain uh in the loop of these
autonomous systems I think the first uh
thing that I would say is that the in
the loop on the loop out of the loop
terminology is not really up to Snuff so
I'm not using it anymore um because the
whole notion of having a a system under
meaningful human control that is
basically the state-of-the-art
conceptually speaking um in terms of
like how we're talking about this does
not mean a human in the loop or remotely
piloted meaningful human control um um
can mean full autonomy in the weapon
system so it can mean that the whole
human machine system is set up in a way
that the human is not no longer
performing any of those functions in the
targeting site
the machine is doing all of it and still
you would consider this to be under
meaningful human control because the
system was designed to be controllable
and it is used in a way that when it's
activated the human operator can foresee
what is going to happen can administer
it when you know something goes wrong or
when he or she wants to and that
everything that happens is um you know
retraceable to the human due to you know
being able to have a legal you know
chain of accountability
this is obviously a way more complex way
of thinking about this than saying well
human should always be in control in
terms of well so remotely pting basic
doing everything remotely that is not
what people are talking about when we're
when they're saying we want meaningful
human control over weapons the question
really now is like how do we do this and
the answer is we do it in a
differentiated context dependent manner
so let's stick with this notion of
Defending against incoming Munitions say
you're a you're a nabe
now and you're on the high seas and you
scanning The Horizon you know what's
around you and there's most definitely
no Bus full of nuns M you know by a
sheer Miracle flying through the air
that's that is not happening uh let's
now let's say there's a couple of
contacts coming your way like very fast
and this is probably a bunch of
anti-ship missiles it would be I think
arguably a very good idea in fact to
then flip that switch and have that frig
autonomously in in that way defend
itself against all these incoming
targets and save the lives of the crew
and you would consider this to be un
meaningful human control you would know
what would happen um you would be able
to deactivate at any point in time and
if something were to happen and it's as
I said quite unlikely it would be clear
like who's responsible because we had
the proper techn tactics techniques
procedures and regulations in place if
you have a similar system and the the us
for instance they explained this once at
the UN in Geneva um they have a system
similar to fallons which they use on
Navy vessels um which they use uh on a
trailer basically for land operations
and they would park this in front of a
forward operating base and they took out
the option of even putting this into
fully autonomous mode because they were
saying it's way too dangerous you know
there's so much cluttered stuff like
people are walking by maybe there's a
boy on a bike now there's a football
there's birds in the air there's all
kinds of things are happening maybe
there is the the Bus full of nuns
driving through the through the you know
through through that whole scenario and
so you need a completely different set
of rules to operate this thing to have
it under meaningful human control and
lastly you know if let's say you're uh
infantry in an urban environment and
you're using some something like this
what I mentioned before the Albert lanus
system that some quadcopter that is also
has maybe some explosives or some
weapons to kill people with even
you wouldn't be throwing this into a
building and just say well kill
everything that moves or has like
roughly 37 degree you know body
temperature you would be doing something
like looking humans looking at the feet
making judgments about what is happening
and so to get back to the original
question what is the human's role it I
would say it depends but it should be as
much as
possible depend depending on the
situation I'm not saying these people on
the frig need to die just just because
we can't be using autonomy they can use
this to defend themselves but I think
those infantry folks in the urban
environment they will have to also um
accept maybe some more risk to them
maybe it would be easier to just have
you know a bunch of Slaughter Bots go in
there and kill everyone but they would
have to expect uh um they would have to
be under the obligation lawfully to
accept some risk to be able to make the
judgments that humans need to be making
which is who's a combatant who's a
civilian who may I you know who can I be
engaging with which amount of force
that's also another thing that humans
need to be making we need to be
discriminate we need to be proportionate
we need to be cautious under attack
that's stuff that is just coming out of
the law and it's directed at humans
humans are supposed to be making these
decisions and they need to be doing this
and I think they will be doing this for
quite a while because machines as far as
I can see are incapable
of these discrimination decisions they
are most certainly unable to come up
with what we would call a proportionate
attack in a split second in a specific
situation we wouldn't even know how to
train systems to be able to make these
kinds of judgments H and so yeah the the
it all goes back to who or what is
deciding what when and where and just
that depends on the operational context
and we should be
having humans do the stuff that humans
are good at and we were super good at
you know understanding
situations um rather than just
recognizing uh objects in an in an image
we know what happens who what is he
doing over there why is she running out
of that house a machine will not
understand we have an immediate notion
of what is happening and humans should
be doing this and we can automate other
things stuff that you machines are good
at and so it all goes back to there's no
really black and white super easy answer
here it is complicated but it's not too
complicated I think we can figure it out
we've figured out other complicated
stuff in the past and we've come up with
rules to make it work in a way that we
would say is you know compliant with the
law and you know in line with our ethics
and is not getting us into extra risk
yeah we can imagine looking at an enemy
uh and then having to make the decision
okay is this is this enemy intending to
to surrender that that's
extracting information about the
intention of a person in an image is is
probably beyond the capabilities of of
current autonomous systems but it it's
very much something that that humans
evolve to do that's a fantastic picture
I saw it in one of those image
recognition papers and it's it's um it's
like a backstage like a
hallway and it's Barack Obama and a
bunch of other people in his you know it
well listeners this is a this is an
image where Obama is playing a prank on
another
uh I I I'm guessing official so
government official where where Obama is
leaning on the way to make the the
person way more than he actually does
exactly and and everybody's laughing in
the picture and it's like you look at
this and you immediately get get the
prank you get why it's funny you get why
everybody's laughing and it's just it's
a fun picture ask a machine what is
happening in that picture yeah you won't
get a good answer although I will say I
think uh we can try to to to feed that
image to to a large language model yeah
in in the perhaps near future and and
things might be different here might be
a good place to distinguish two phrases
this is a bit of legal terminology so we
have meaningful human control versus
appropriate appropriate human judgment
to to Outsiders this this sounds like
this is probably the same but perhaps
you can explain why why context matters
here and and why these phrases are
actually pretty different uh they are in
fact quite different and uh it's also
the second phrase is appropriate levels
of human judgment even so it makes it
makes it even more um I'd say abstract
in a way so um the US was quite early
with regard to all of this also in terms
of putting out regulation they have a
document uh with the number 3.09 called
directive on autonom weapon systems and
they issued this for the first time in
2012 and now they are I think in their
third Rev of this document and this
notion that you let out this appropriate
levels of human judgment is still very
much um like the archimedian point in
the way they think about this like
everybody everything revolves around
these appropriate levels of human
judgment the notion is kind of the way I
described it before that humans do human
things and machines do machine things
and the way the doctrine thinks about
this is that um we will keep this in a
way that is IHL compliant and a
responsible way to deal with it by
making sure that we have appropriate
levels of human judgment in that whole
system and that basically starts with
the with the conception and the initial
designs of the weapon system and the
prototyping and the you know procurement
and the certification and validation and
in the end the actual use of that
system and people looked at this and
they were like that's a bit too vague
for my taste basically they were saying
what are these what when do we know when
human judgment whatever that is um is
appropriate at which point and how is
the human judgment being fed into that
system and so that is how meaningful
human control basically came about that
people were saying we need something
that is more specific
and impressing on on everyone that we we
want the human to be in a stronger role
in this human machine relationship that
we're talking about which is what we're
talking about because we're not talking
about a category of weapons we're
talking about functions and who's doing
what and yeah that that that's how it
came about meaningful human control um
which kind of at the beginning
was like an empty
signifier I perceived it as something
that wasn't fully fleshed out when it
was put out but it is it's it's just
um it turned out to be a very useful
concept because the more people thought
about this that we want okay we want
human something do we want human
judgment maybe judgment is is not really
enough maybe we want control okay we
want human control now what kind of
human control do we want well we don't
want the human to be sitting in a booth
looking at a screen and whenever the
screen turns green we want the human to
be pushing but we we don't want a rubber
stamp exactly we want actual like
meaningful human control that's what we
want we want humans to be understanding
what it is that they're doing and so
this is kind of how it came about um and
this is how meaningful human control is
conceptually speaking a a stronger idea
putting more emphasis on the human role
in the human machine uh
interfacing um and how it separates from
appropriate levels of human
judgment um and then you know all the
rest came all the rest came afterwards
like this the things that I was
basically listing before when I was
saying needs to be um foreseeable what
happens the system needs to be
administrable there needs to be
traceability for to be human uh legally
accountable all these kind of things
control in use control by Design those
came afterwards this is when like re
research groups uh groups and and you
know just different um groups and people
working on this came up uh with ideas
how we how could we flesh out meaningful
human controls so that it is actually in
the end in specific operational contexts
appable and so we can we can make it so
that the human machine team is working
in a way that we would say from the
outside okay the system as a whole is
under meaningful control perhaps we
should discuss the political
possibilities here so why is it
difficult to to regulate autonomy uh if
if we think International I think one of
the reasons um should be fairly evident
from our conversation that we were
having it is a bit more complicated than
for instance counting nuclear warheads
we we might say that's complicated
enough to count nuclear warheads yeah it
is I mean uh also doing it in a way so
you can do verification without giving
away any of the secrets so you would
make the yeah that's difficult stuff but
you probably won't have as hard a Time
agreeing on what a nuclear warhead is um
and so that part definitely is easier
compared to everybody agreeing on what
we're talking about when we're talking
about autonomy weapons is and I know
this for a fact because I was at the
from the from the get-go and in the
beginning people were talking about
drones and then for a while we were
talking about Terminator and then we
were talking about the category of
weapons and nobody was able to Define
what this category is and then finally
you know IC and and some other you know
strong voices they were saying well it's
about selection engagement of targets
without human intervention and then it
Dawn on everybody well then it's
basically a functional issue so we need
to be thinking about this in terms of
the functionality and who's doing what
and so that took a while as I said took
took me quite a while and um the the
process in the UN is I think Super
valuable and and great because it gave
this learning opportunity to everybody
to the states to Civil Society to
academics and so we learned about this
and we are now where we are which is we
kind of know what it is that we're
talking about we also know what we
should be doing about it I I was saying
we can regulate if we if we were to say
we want meaningful human control
depending on operational context
obviously the finer you you can you have
to granulate this like finer and finer
depending on what it is that you're
talking about like the frigate or the
Infantry peeps in the in the urban
environment but you could be saying BL
this is what we want and this is also
how a lot of international law works it
sets a super abstract norm and says this
is the Norm this is what we want what it
specifically means in specific contexts
is quite removed from that and nobody
would expect like an international legal
document to spell that out for everybody
in in the in its finest detail but we
could be agreeing on that Norm now why
don't we why is it so hard it's not
because we haven't understood at this
point what it is that we're talking
about we have if you meet people who in
2023 say well we haven't defined what a
lethal autonomous weapon system is you
you can say well either you have no idea
what you're talking about or you're
trying to stall the process that people
will still say this in the UN and you
know you're just doing it to just pump
The Brak so we're not getting anywhere
why is that the case is it specifically
adding the phrase legal to autonomous
weapon systems or what is it that's
Lethal lethal yeah well okay that that's
another thing yeah that The lethality
part the so it's two reasons why is it
that you would still meet someone would
say lethal autonomous weapon systems we
don't have them defined yet and so we
can't enact any regulation like I said
the getting the complicated uh business
done and understanding what it is that
we're talking about that's done why are
we still not enacting any rules on it
because there's no political will people
uh will for instance um rather spend
months debating about you know The
lethality part of autonomous weapon
systems which is the moniker that is
being used in the UN LW La WS which is
how it started and the way the UN works
is you know at at some point in the dawn
of
time uh you know regarding the the
discussion of autonomic weapon systems
someone thought it would be a good idea
to name it this way and then they all
agreed upon this and there's no way
going back from this it's only very very
slightly that we're trying to move away
from this in newer documents that I
looked at you know just the other day
that are being circulated at the in
Geneva where they're trying to drop the
L because you don't need lethality in
there first of all lethality is a
consequence of a use of force you attack
someone and then it's that ends up being
lethal it is not necessarily A
characterization of the weapon system
you using you know non-lethal or less
than lethal weapons can of course be
used in a way so that they're lethal so
it doesn't make any sense to put that in
there from the get-go and also um that
is something that we haven't talked Al
about but that is also of course an
issue imagine like a huge system of
non-lethal weapons autonomously dealing
out violence something like a social
scoring system coupled to a drone swarm
where if you jwalk you immediately get
tasered by a drone autonomously like
this is this is a terrible oppressive
thing and it is autonomous in autonomy
in weapon systems but you know no one
would be saying well that's okay because
it's not lethal of course it's not okay
it's a terrible terrible notion so you
don't need the lethal part the the AWS
part of the law part uh moniker the AWS
part is fine as long as you translate it
is as autonomy in weapon systems and why
don't people uh you know do anything
about it because I was alluding to this
before even before Russia attacked
Ukraine in 2022 attacked it again uh one
should say we were kind of stuck uh at
the the UN in Geneva at the
CCW
and to be perfectly honest the the
pandemic
um I thought well all of a sudden the
pandemic made it possible for us to
watch it from remotely via you and web
TV and I was like o that's an option now
now I don't have to you know go there uh
in person anymore and it also kind of as
soon as you were removed from the room
and you saw like how dismal the process
really is even though it was very
valuable in terms of creating this
learning curve and it's still a valuable
process to have I'm not saying we should
be no longer be talking about this but
it is not a process that you can expect
to produce anything tangible the CCW
will not produce any new law on this
that is fairly certain wrapping up here
uh the final question is where are we in
the process of regulating autonomous
weapon systems what are the prospects of
uh getting some form of of Norm or
prohibitions established maybe a treaty
maybe maybe via soft law what do you
think so it's not as Bleak as uh maybe
it it sounded when I was speaking about
the process at the CCW and how terribly
stalled it is there um because there is
stuff happening at the UN General
Assembly first Committee in New York
there will be a resolution hopefully um
that will be uh not a huge but an
important step because uh while it's not
necessarily opening up a new forum for
this it will task the Secretary General
to do additional things on this and just
give civil society and and you know
other stakeholders in this process an
additional lever to pull on and say we
need to be doing something about this
and and if the SE gen for instance came
back and where to say I recommend the
International Community to be doing
something about this to open
negotiations that would you know make
this lever even more powerful and we
could maybe you know get states to
finally sit down and talk about uh the
issue with a bit more substance I mean
that's something that most people also I
think don't understand we have never
negotiated this it's just been talked
about so everything that has happened in
the UN was just discussion nothing is
really under negotiation in terms of
we're
negotiating rules or binding treaties or
new international law and so um I'm not
without any hope but it is a marathon
and not a Sprint I think what needs to
be done is clear um we kind of put it
together in our conversation quite
nicely I think there's just a thing that
should be prohibited that would be
weapons that select and engage targets
without human intervention going after
specific biometric signatures that would
just something that I would outlaw and
if we were to come up with binding rules
they should say in a very abstract
manner no weapon systems that cannot be
put under meaningful human control that
is in its most abstract sense which I
think the International Community should
be agreeing upon and as long as that is
not possible
because specific States just do not want
to move forward on this even an inch I
think it's important to just um have
domestic process on this like I've been
active in Germany trying to tell people
hey we can we can do something we can
have a Doctrine we can have a like an
official document saying the German
armed forces the bundes is going to use
this in this and that and that manner
but we will never be doing this that and
the other and then maybe compare this to
what the french are doing and the Dutch
are doing and the Brits are doing and
the US are doing and maybe come up with
good you know best practices also to
give to to help build this what I was
calling before like this proton Norm
people know that you just don't rush
into this and to flash out this proton
norm and give people a more and more um
clear idea of how we can be using this
and the things that we should definitely
avoid and um I think this way we could
at least be coming to something like uh
like soft law before we get to anything
binding like something like a catalog of
best practices or a code of conduct or
something which is not great like I
would hope for something that is way
stronger than this but you know as
someone who's been doing this for a
decade now I'd be happy with at least
something that we then can build upon
because as I said it's a marathon not a
Sprint unfortunate Frank thanks for
coming on the podcast it's been a
pleasure talking to you